case interviews are a key component of
the recruiting process of
large consulting firms such as mbb for
many candidates preparing the cases is
one of the most time consuming
and one of the most stressful parts of
getting ready for the interview process
but do you know how a strong and stellar
case interview performance
actually looks like many people struggle
with this so today we are going to
jointly look into a video that was
published on the official channel of the
consulting
firm bain and company bane is as you
know part of mbb it's one of the large
leading consulting firms and they posted
a model case interview a mock
case interview on the web page
illustrating what they perceive to be a
great performance
and the idea for this video actually
came from youtube because i
saw in my analytics statistics that this
is a video that a large majority of you
guys already watched
so i thought then why don't we look into
this together and i will give you my
reaction i will give you my perspective
so welcome to another coffee break here
on my channel firm learning
my name is heinrich i'm a former
mckinsey consultant and on this channel
i try to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career i'm
happy to be in the office now in the
last weeks i spent several days now in
the mountains
doing a little vacation in the alps we
had an amazing time
and i hope now you see what i did here
because i now use this little video
to say thank you to my first members to
my first sponsors of this
channel so as some of you might have
already noticed there's a new button
if you go next to the subscribe button
there should be a new
join button and since a couple of days
you can support me by becoming a member
of this channel and thereby
also gain some perks so i very much
appreciate that and thanks again to the
first people now already deciding to
become a member
this is really helping me a lot much
appreciated but now without further ado
let's
jump into the video so here we are this
is the video
mock consulting interview consultant on
the official bain and company careers
channel
it has over 500 000 views so quite a
big and successful video and the like to
dislike ratio is pretty great as well so
i'd say let's just
check it out
danielle hi hi welcome to maine thank
you
i'm emily nice to meet you nice to meet
you too okay follow me
okay so you can directly see something
so he was apparently sitting there alone
in the waiting for the interviewer
so why this might be the case for some
of the firms i've also seen many
processes where then you would sit
together in a room with other candidates
and then one after the other or some
parallel you get interviewed
so it's not necessarily the case that
you are sitting there alone
often it's then a larger assessment day
with other candidates present this way
hey uh so i propose that we just jump
right into the case and
um get started how does that feel yeah
let's do it
okey-dokey so i'm going to keep my
computer screen open and
there's a few pieces of data and some
graphs that i might want to show you
but otherwise i'm ready when you are
yeah i'm ready
great our client is next gen tech
and they've created a wearable device
called the theo and
theo is essentially a little computer on
your wrist
it tracks activity so it tells you your
calories your steps
it also can accept text messages it's
basically
a fully connected device next gen tech
wants theo
to make one billion dollars over the
next two years
in the us they
brought us in because they have a bit of
a problem
theo has wi-fi built in
which is great but that connectivity
is only available currently when it has
wi-fi so
they want to partner with a cellular
carrier to provide that connectivity
and they've talked to verizon and at t
the two biggest players in the u.s
and verizon and 18t are excited about
the opportunity but they have said that
they will
only work with next gen tech and with
theo if they are the only two providers
so what next gen tech asked us to come
in and help them answer is
should they go with 18t and verizon and
an exclusive
relationship or should they pursue a
partnership with other carriers
um great so let me summarize the case
for you to make sure i got all the
yeah so here so what she did is now she
posts the case and the way she did it is
very typical she gives you
a description of a business problem and
usually what these interviewers do is
that everybody comes up with his own
personal case
so it's not the case that they have a
library from which then they pull
cases but usually the consulting
interviewers are asked
based on their own consulting experience
so based on projects they
actually did and of course sanitize the
situation and then draft the case based
on that
and therefore often when you then
discuss these cases with the
interviewers you can assume that the
interviewer has quite extensive
knowledge on the topic
and probably has already spent lots of
days and nights thinking about the
solutions to the things that are being
discussed and now of course what this
guy is doing is here great as well
because he said okay let me summarize
so let's see what exactly you're
summarizing details
our client is next-gen tech uh client
has developed this wearable device
called theo
which is like a computer on your wrist
it tracks your fitness calories you get
tax from it
and our goal here is to make theo a 1
billion
dollar revenue is that correct yep
revenue and
in the us only yes we're only talking
about the us right now okay
uh and here indeed what you can see is
that he is asking some clarifying
questions so what is the scope did i
understand the units correctly
and this is important because it might
happen that you just misunderstand
something that you you know
somebody says hey and maybe you just
imply something else in it
and then just by getting this out of the
way asking these questions it can really
help you
to not get derailed from the case just
from the very beginning which would of
course be a pity um one complication is
that
the device has wi-fi built in but
our client wants to wants it to work
like anywhere even when wi-fi is not
available so they want to partner with
some
cellular carriers and the options we
have
are basically one at t and verizon
partnering with 18 verizon
but they demand exclusivity
or following other carriers you got it
can i ask you one more question
sure are we planning to sell this device
only through
uh like the carrier's stores yeah for
now that's our distribution channel is
going to be through 18t and verizon or
other carrier stores great you might if
i take some
some time to organize my thoughts go for
it all right
and this is now important this way so
whenever you are you know faced with
such a question in the case
almost never this expected from you that
you just you know start talking without
any preparation and so on
and in most cases this is actually
negative and we reflect on you as being
unstructured as being
unorganized so it's always well worth
the time to say okay can i just take a
moment to organize my thoughts
and then in these kind of situations
they always will say yes
and then just try to come up with some
kind of structure so ideally you have a
couple of things in your mind
that you believe now should be evaluated
should be looked into and then you
organize
them into some groups very often the
number is
three so it's often great to then have
three groups of things that you wanna
look into
and then you can go group by group and
discuss that but for that to do that
it's completely fair to just take a
minute or so and just structure your
thoughts on a piece of paper
so our goal is to make the old uh one
billion
dollar business in the us in revenue in
the next two years
yeah and the options the question i have
to answer is to
where to go with 18 verizon and sign an
exclusivity contract
or follow other carriers you got it uh
to assess the
this problem i would like to look uh to
market size
of of the carriers to the customer base
and the retail footprint of the options
okay so
under market size i like to understand
since
the the carriers will be the only
logistics the footprint that the stores
will be the only
way of selling the product i like to
understand the number of customers
we currently have uh for for 18 verizon
and the other option
uh what is the price we'll be selling to
to to these clients
sure uh and what is the growth expected
between year one and two
under customer base i would like to
understand the demographics
of the of the customers understand their
price sensitivity sensitivity
and to assess the likelihood of
the the customer base to purchase our
product make sense
and finally i would like to look at the
retail footprint
and see what was the number of stores we
currently have
for the options and what's the sales
force available
okay i like that so let's pause here and
there are two things that are noteworthy
about what he did here so first i hope
you recognize that what this guy did
is an example of top-down communication
because now instead of directly going
into the nitty-gritty details and
looking into something
what he said is okay we need to look
into three
aspects the market size the customer
base and then the third one dimension so
introduces the overall structure the key
elements
and then he goes element by element and
breaks it down into the
the key sub components of that so this
way of talking about it is almost always
superior
then just directly starting with the
first and then kind of getting lost in
the elements of the first
without anybody really having understood
the full framework
so this is an example of top-down
communication if you want to learn more
about that check out the video i will
link it
somewhere above here it's the video
where i talked about top-down
communication in detail
but there's another second thing to
learn here as well because notice how he
used this sheet of paper
where he collected and organized his
thoughts and used that as a basis for
discussion
so this is always something that works
really well not only in interview
situations but also when you're really
sitting together with clients
but you just do a basic sketch a basic
drawing
probably the three key elements you will
have on the piece of paper and then the
bullets of the two three four
most important sub dimensions and if you
then show this to the interviewer and
then guide him through the whole
framework all of this will become much
more clear to the interview it will be
much more tangible
and this will for sure help you of
course i understand that now
the current situation with video calls
of course that might be more difficult
uh where do you want to start i would
like to start by the market size if
that's fine
that works for me so first of all i'd
like to understand what is the
price with 18 t and verizon our
expectation is that we'll sell
the theo for four hundred dollars
and uh with other carriers our
expectation is that we would sell it for
five hundred dollars
is there a reason for that good question
so part of what makes 18 verizon 18 teen
verizon
good partners is that they would be
willing to throw in a little bit of
money to bring down the cost
um that customers would have to pay
walking out the door with you so
18 t and verizon are essentially helping
to subsidize that 400
cost makes sense i'd like to know the
current number of customers we have
okay um why do you want to understand
that zone assess like the total market
potential market and calculate the
penetration rate so you can see how
feasible it is to to get
to one billion revenue got it for each
of the options okay so i have a little
bit of data for you then
let me share that with you
okay so i have the customer base for a
tnt
and verizon another uh which includes
sprinting mobile us cellular cricket
it's pretty
uh granular um so this is for
the current customer base right correct
um right now
do we have the expected customer base
next year why do you want to understand
that
because we we want to like our goals to
get to one billion revenue in year two
um and i would like to calculate the
penetration rate yeah next year
so we do have some growth rates um we
know um the growth rate
so let's just briefly stop here so what
you see is that this is now the
calculation part of the case
and indeed almost every case will have
both a qualitative component
and a quantitative component so the
qualitative component is where you
structure a problem
similar to what this guy did earlier and
now the quantitative component
is where you actually need to do some
calculations so to be ready to do
calculations with pen and paper with no
calculators this is what you're usually
expected to do so practice written
division written multiplication
and not only by rounding it but really
getting to the very exact number if this
is necessary in some instances
because this is what will be sometimes
expected from you in these case
interviews
wait for um both
um 18 verizon as well as for other
carriers this is about 20 percent
give this back to you in case you need
these numbers okay
so what i would do to calculate the
penetration rates is
first of all i would estimate the
potential market
by multiplying the number of customers
and
in year two which means i will calculate
them for customers
with 20 growth rate okay um and divide 1
billion
by this number which is the penetration
rate doesn't make sense to you
yeah i think so why when you just start
and then we can keep going
and again notice what he did here so
before now starting with the
calculations
he told the lady what his calculation
method would be so what exactly he is
going to calculate
and this is important for two reasons
first if you don't do this and in the
end you just tell the person interviewer
number
then of course this number might be
wrong for all kinds of reasons but if
the interviewer knows
nothing else about what you're doing
then he just assumes that you just got
it wrong right and then you will just
lose on that part of the interview but
if you already from the very beginning
start explaining the logic of what
you're doing then first by that you can
already
show in your interview that you're
actually doing the right thing
and if then you mess up with some little
math thing in the process then maybe
this will be something that he can
actually help you with and just show you
a little error that you maybe did and
here also the truth is that usually in
these interviews if you do a minor math
error or something like that this will
not kick you out right
but you need to enable the interview to
help you to help your logic to help your
calculations to then really get you back
on track again because if you don't do
it then this might really completely
derail the case and then you're stuck
and then you cannot proceed
i have number of customers for option
one which is
a t and verizon and option two
which is which are the other characters
so the growth rate is 20
we get to the number of customers
in year 2 okay which is 24 million for
18 to verizon and 36 million just
added one percent to each of them okay
and here also just to pause so just to
calibrate yourself what is expected from
you what types of calculations are
expected from you
and indeed usually you should always be
fine to then in a written formal way
do multiplications through the visions
if this is required
but of course whenever possible whenever
it makes sense if you can just do
basic little calculations in your head
in your mind just some mental math
of course that will always be portrayed
as more confident
be always portrayed as a bit quicker in
your head right a bit more smart
than if you just always do a formal
written calculation and here indeed if
you have a calculation something like
30 million times 1.2 then this is indeed
something where you should be able to
come up with a result just by mental
math and not by now formally writing the
calculation out
20 times 1.2 yeah okay now we have the
price
per device for each of the scenarios and
here we have
400 dollars fourteen to verizon
and five hundred dollars for
option two all right by multiplying
these two i'll get to the
potential total market size assuming you
have like 100 penetration
okay so this is the total mark not 9.6
billion
and one point uh 18 okay
option two uh since we want one billion
uh revenue in here two i would divide
one billion by nine point six
and uh my final so in this case i will
approximate to ten percent if that's
fine with you and here's one billion by
eighteen again approximately five
percent if that's fine
that sounds good yeah so both so here
again sometimes it's completely okay
just to round the numbers as he also did
it
but indeed again as this candidate also
did i would always ask your interviewer
if it's okay just to proceed with a
rounded number
because sometimes they also just want to
test you and want to see whether you are
actually able with
written math to solve a more complex
problem
to the correct digit so don't just
assume that you can round but ask and
then often sometimes you might be okay
and then you can proceed this way
both penetration rates seem relatively
low
of course option two seems easier to
achieve however
since the we have more carriers it's
more granular it's harder to probably
standardize
um any uh go to market strategy they
have
so i would so in a vacuum five percent
seems better than 10 penetration but
because but because option two is the
other carriers and that's really
fragmented that could be potentially
really exactly
got it okay so uh going back to my
framework uh
the next step i'd like to to to take is
to look at the customer base
and understand who our customer
uh our customers are um what are they
what they value
when acquiring uh a product from from
their
their carriers the way to do that would
be probably to run a survey a customer
survey we
definitely did do a customer survey and
i'm excited to share it with you
so you can see here that so now i just
want to also share my observation that
this
somehow seems a little bit too staged
this whole interview right because
always whenever he is saying something
then just suddenly
she exactly had the data prepared so
this seems a bit too staged
so most interviews this is not how you
can really expect it to go because very
rarely the candidate will always give
the exact
pointers that then lead to the data that
the interviewer has prepared
so more frequently than not it will be
also the interviewer who probably guides
you a bit
more through the different steps and
then will be able to also provide you
then some data proactively
whenever he feels like that you know
it's necessary now to move to the next
step
and then he wants to share your
perspective on that as well
this tells us what is the most important
selection criteria for
18 to verizon and the other carriers so
i'm assuming these numbers here are like
the sample size which means the number
of customers interviewed in the survey
you're right yep
great uh 14th verizon the two uh most
important selection criterias are
reliability of the network
and customer service so i'm assuming att
verizon provide
a better network and a better customer
service
on the other hand the other carriers are
very concerned about price they're very
price sensitive which tells me that
since our product is like a new product
and we're looking for early adopters
uh early adopters are probably not very
price sensitive so
it seems like 18 to verizon customers
have a better fit for our product okay
i that that makes sense to me so here
also
very closely listen to what he said and
what he did right and just first of all
i'd like you to notice that this is also
a
typical component of a case interview
namely that you are
getting a chart just some data on a
chart that then you are supposed to look
at
and here the main thing that is expected
from you need to recognize is
that they want you to look at the chart
and to draw some conclusions from the
things
that you see so first of all look at it
and try to ask yourself what do i learn
from this
relative to the overall case question
and specifically what you should not do
is just
describing what you see right so this is
not about just
talking about what the numbers are and
what you're seeing but in the end the
question is always
what is the implication what is the
famous
so what what is the so what that we get
from the chart
what do we learn for our project for the
case that we want to answer
so make sure that in the end always
you're able then also to draw this
implication to draw this conclusion
and present that as a finding do not
just repeat
what is seen there on the chart
and so do you feel like you have enough
information yeah
since the like the distribution
channels we're talking about are the
carriage stores uh i'd like to
understand like take a look at the
retail footprint available sure and see
what uh
what is the number of stores each of the
options have how good is the sales force
and do you have do you have any data on
that i do in fact
here we go of course she has data on
that come on guys
so here we have the the number of stores
in the us
and outside of the us focusing first on
the us
i can see that 18 t and verizon combined
have 4 000 stores
and all the other carriers combined have
only 3 000 stores
so we're talking about for option one at
verizon we had 33
more stores and outside of
the u.s that's not true however since
our goal is
in the next two years at least is to
focus only in the u.s
i don't think it's a problem right now
seems fair yes so again
the titan verizon seem a better fit for
our product
okay so great so we have a meeting with
the ceo tomorrow and she asked us to
come in
and let her know what we've learned so
far what our recommendation is based on
what we've learned
any risks that we perceive and if we
have any next steps
great do you mind if it takes some
seconds so guys i hope that you
recognize now that this is the very same
example
that i talked about a couple of weeks
ago in my video of top down
communication
so this is already this practice example
that you see all the time in consultant
namely a ceo
or a partner walking into a room and
asking you okay
what is the status what is going on this
is exactly now what the candidate here
is supposed to prepare
and this is indeed a typical question in
the end of a case interview
that you are asking to summarize your
results your findings to a senior guy
who just happens to walk in
in here now this guy apparently still
gets a couple of minutes or a couple of
seconds to organize his thoughts
often also in these interview situations
the interviewer will say no no the guy
is standing there right in front of you
right you gotta take notes now you need
to answer right away just to put you in
a bit of pressure
and just see what your instincts are how
you're going to answer and now this is
the very moment
where you need to show that you know
what top down communication is
that you got that right so let's see
what this guy's doing now
so my final recommendation would be to
go with ntt
verizon okay option one um and the
reason for that is that
the penetration rates seem very
reasonable for both options
however the the customer base for 18
indian verizon customers
seem a better fit to our product because
the
our customers are the customers are less
price sensitive
and are more likely to be early adopters
of this this new device okay
the main distribution channel will be
the carrier's uh
stores 18 verizon they have more storage
like 33
more stores and since this device i feel
like
customers need to like try it on and
make sure it fit and look well uh it's a
good
it's a good reason to have it it's good
to have more stores yeah next steps
are first of all follow up on the risks
and
then and finally get the law team to to
to ride the contract and get the best
turns possible for us
great uh you're done good job so here
what indeed the guy did is to follow the
top down communication framework right
so to start with the result
and then tell the main reasons here i
believe that the second part
felt a bit too unstructured a bit too
random
i think what would have helped to make
it even more punchy is to say
okay this is our recommendation and now
to get to the recommendation we looked
into three things
market penetration customer base and
added it and then for the market
presentation this is what we learned for
this
this is what we learned for this this is
what we learned and then i also liked
how in the end
then ended with the next steps okay what
are the next things
that we want to look into now to further
solidify
this finding so overall this is the
top-down communication framework so
check out this one video did a couple of
weeks ago and there to learn more about
it
thank you uh so next steps on our side
is that we will
let you know if you make it through to
the next round and you should get a call
from us thanks for being excited about
bain
and thanks for coming in and doing a
case with me
thank you thank you for having me it's
really good to meet you i hope that was
helpful and as always if you have any
questions feel free to leave me a
comment
below in the comment section and i will
do my very best to answer every single
comment if you took
any value out of this video at all
please smash the like button for the
youtube algorithm and also subscribe to
my channel to stay up to date on my
content i release
weekly videos every single saturdays and
if you want to see even more from me
also follow me on my instagram my
instagram handle is firm learning
and i also have a mailing list you can
sign up to that via the link that is
provided in the video description
and last but not least i want again to
invite you to join my channel as a
member
this would mean the world to me you will
find the join button either also as a
link in the video description or next to
the subscribe button so check that out
for some perks but most importantly for
my eternal and sincere
gratitude thank you guys looking forward
to seeing all of you again
soon this is heine from from learning
and bye bye